[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALLAN NAIM: So by way of
intro, I'm Allan Naim.
I'm on the product
management team at Google.
I work on Google
Kubernetes Engine.
And these days,
I've been spending
most of my time working on
how to bring Google Kubernetes
Engine outside of Google
Cloud primarily on premise.
GRACE MOLLISON: Hi I'm Grace.
I'm a cloud solutions architect.
And as part of my role, I get
to talk to lots of customers.
And I am looking for
repeating patterns
that I can then figure
out how to share
those learnings [? via ?]
solutions and tutorials.
So Allan, I'm here to
actually talk to you about why
customers move to the cloud.
So I'm going to talk about
a subset of our customers,
financial services customers.
So why are they
moving to the cloud?
It's not because it's a fact.
It's because they've
got some solid reasons,
as you can see as to why
they'd want to do this.
So one of the key ones fresh out
the door tends to be agility.
I'll sit down and I start
saying I want to be more agile.
They want their developers
to be able to experiment
without them having to kind
of invest in upfront Capex.
They're also in a lot
of cases, their network
isn't actually designed
for global collaboration
and global delivery.
So obviously, they
think of the cloud
will help them to do that.
And obviously with
the scale of GCP,
that will obviously help them.
And then they've
got, over the time,
they've had lots of problems
with single points failure,
because the way
things have developed.
So they're thinking about
how they can actually
provide better availability.
And because when you
design for the cloud,
we actually kind
of encourage you
to think about failures
up front, because things
fail all the time.
And then there's the cost
optimization, which they also
are kind of key.
So some of the workloads
this subset think about
are risk and
regulated reporting.
They've got more and
more data and rules
that they need to comply with.
So they want to do lots of
analytics and big data type
crunching, so things they need
to prove that they're actually
doing as they say.
Then there's financial
risk modeling, lots of CPU.
And they're also
always developing
new consumer applications.
ALLAN NAIM: So Grace,
you're out there
talking to a lot of customers
and having conversations
around their cloud journey.
What are some of the challenges
that you're seeing out there?
GRACE MOLLISON: I knew you
were going to ask that.
So as been financial services,
one of the first things
out the door is regulations.
They're global.
So not only have
they got to deal
with regulations
for local regions,
but also global regulations.
And as well as
just regulations, I
speak to all the teams
that have an influence
and actually use the platforms.
So let's have a look at
what the infrastructure
teams tend to require.
They have locality concerns
as well, so two types.
It's the workload.
Some of the workloads
can be run on premises.
Some can be run on the cloud.
In addition to that, they've
got where can your data be?
They want to be able
to classify their data,
because they just cannot
move that data to the cloud.
And even when it
gets to the cloud,
it's like, oh, hang on a minute.
Where in the cloud can it be?
So they won't actually
pin it to a region.
And when that data
moves up, they also
want to be able to identify it.
They're also very, very
concerned about the fact
that they've got to
run their operations
across a hybrid platform.
So they're worried about the
technical complexity of that.
So I spoke earlier about the
single points of failure.
So it's all about
business continuity.
So the fact that they
want their infrastructure
and their application interfaces
to be designed and built
for resiliency.
And also they want to
make sure that their calls
to those interfaces are
authenticate and authorized.
They want to have
logical separation.
They want to be able to
distinguish between workloads
and team projects.
And then they want guardrails.
Basically, they want to
be able to propagate rules
from the organization
downwards without getting
in the way of the developers.
So they want to mitigate
against potential human error.
They want to actually
stop ne'er do wells
having unauthorized access.
And they want to be able to
get signals for all of this.
They want to be able to monitor
that hybrid architecture,
whether it be on platform
or on prem or in the cloud.
And there's consistency of the
infrastructure and the policies
that apply across
both platforms.
The security team have also
got very similar requirements
as well.
They also want to be
able to classify data.
And they have issues around
where certain data should be.
They want to be able to
integrate their security
controls as part of their
pipeline deployment,
be that whether it's
infrastructure's code
to actually deploy to the
actual infrastructure,
or whether it's
application codes.
They want those controls
to be as part of those
that deployment and they want
it to be a first class citizen.
Data integrity-- they
want to make sure
that secure access to data.
One thing there's a
common ask is like, OK,
once we've got our
data in the cloud,
can we prevent it be modified
for a set period of time?
Auditing-- again, here
the actual act of auditing
shouldn't change anything,
forensic auditing.
And they obviously been able
to track who's doing what
in their platform is key.
Separation of duty,
least privilege
is actually two sides
of the same coin.
It's all about permissions.
So if you think about
the fact that you
have a central security
or network team,
that infers you don't want
other teams to have the ability
to change your firewall rules
or other security controls.
So it's making sure people
have the permissions they
need to do their job, and
not over permissioning.
Organization-wide
policies-- that's
essentially the guardrails
the infrastructure team
talked about.
And course, there's developers.
So developers, as we said,
they want to be more agile,
we want to improve the
speed of deployment.
And one of the things
that's come up about,
this is the fact that people
start to adopt microservices,
because it allows
you to work on bits
of your application with
you to different teams.
And they don't get
in each other's ways
because they can actually
independently update
that service, they can
independently scale.
And Kubernetes has
been seen as a way
to do that because you
can run it on prem,
you can run in another
cloud, you can run it on us.
Separation of
duty-- again, that's
all about who can do what.
And here, they're really
concerned about separating out
the operational requirements
from the development
requirements.
Logical separation-- here, it's
isolation between environments.
And that can mean between
different services
or it can mean between
dev, prod and QA.
And then there's isolation
between those workloads
and services.
Developers, they
love CI/CD tooling.
So one of the things that
they wanted to actually have
the same tooling deployed to
whichever platform, be that one
premise or on the cloud.
And they want consistency.
They want to be able to
have one way of signaling
through auditing, reformation
logging, and alerting.
And we're hoping
that you're going
to be able to actually help
us unblock some of these.
ALLAN NAIM: These are
pretty big shoes to fill.
So what better way
to truly understand
all these various requirements
that Grace has walked through
than to actually hear it
from a customer directly?
And I have the
privilege of inviting
Rajay Rai from Macquarie
Bank to come up on stage
and talk about how
they've accomplished
some of these challenges.
So I've been working with Rajay,
here for a couple of months.
And I've been super impressed
at just the level of agility
that his teams have brought
across the entire organization,
helping their teams to be able
to deploy upwards between 60
to 100 deploys per day.
And that's fantastic.
So Rajay, without further ado,
walks through the journey.
RAJAY RAI: Thank you
very much, Allan.
So today I'm going to take
you through a high level
view of what we do
in Macquarie Bank.
And before that, let me
just quickly take you to
through who Macquarie Bank is.
So Macquarie Bank has a
presence in about 27 countries.
We are a global bank, and one
of the largest infrastructure
managers, in fact, one of the
largest infrastructure asset
managers in the world.
We have over about 15,000
employees in Macquarie.
There are five key
divisions than Macquarie.
I work in banking and
financial services,
which is the retail
arm of the business.
I look after digital engineering
at the bank at the moment.
So we are a digital
bank, which means
we have no branches,
absolutely no branches.
The only branch
we have right now
is one branch, which is in
Shelley Street in Sydney.
That's where our head office is.
About four and a
half, five years ago,
we started a journey.
And when we started our
journey, our objective
was to create highly consumable
interactions for our customers.
How do we do that?
How do we take
complex data and make
them more consumable and more
meaningful for our customers?
That was the idea.
There's an example here.
This is my account
actually, where
you could go and say using
natural language search
capabilities, you
could see how much
did I spend in golf
around [? Marunga. ?] I
play a lot of golf.
And you can see that we
have proximity-based search.
And if I have a bad day, I
end up in [? Ton ?] [? Lee, ?]
which is on your left.
There's a red dot there.
That's where I go and kind
of try and improve my swing.
On the left side, we've
got an example of insights,
oversights, and foresights.
About four years ago we
didn't have a mobile presence.
Today we do, and it's
a leading experience
at the moment in Australia.
I mentioned, we
are a digital bank.
And we are also providing wide
level solutions for clients.
We have over around
50 different channels
that we support
today that tells you
the complexity, the
level of complexity
that we have to face in
managing our entire ecosystem.
Wind back to about
five years ago.
This is where we were.
I'm sure all of you
can relate to this--
active passive infrastructure.
And it would take us
about six to eight hours
to deploy a beautiful
infrastructure.
You can see that there are lots
of monolithic applications.
It took us a while.
And then we said, you know, if
we are to be a digital bank,
there's no way we could
survive in a world
where everything is
changing constantly.
So we are all living in the
fourth Industrial Revolution,
where we know that
it's all about the fast
that beats the slow.
And connectivity is new royalty.
So how do you ship
software in minutes?
That's really, really important.
As an organization,
we need to find a way
to help the organization
move faster.
And your software
has to be shippable.
How do we do that?
This is how we've done this.
This is the evolution
that we've been on.
From the right from
their left side,
you will see we started with
monolithic applications, moved
on to microservices.
After that, we
moved all our data
to a data platform, which
I'll explain in more
detail in the next slide.
Experimentation is important.
In order to be
really innovative,
you've got to be able to
learn and innovate fast.
Hence, we'll talk about that
in terms of architecture.
How do we align with that?
How do we complement what
the business wants to do?
Cloud was important.
Moving to the cloud
was fundamental for us.
And of course, with
all of this, we
were the first bank in
Australia to publish open APIs.
We did this last
year, early last year.
That's the pace of innovation
that we have at the moment.
So we went from having the
ability to sequentially
release, which is
maybe once in a month
or once in three
months, to something
like 60 to 100 releases a day.
And we do this
actively in production.
I'll talk a little
more about that.
Our UIs would take roughly
30 seconds to deploy.
And I can tell you
about that as well.
This is our current
state architecture today.
From the bottom, we've
got a system of record
where we're publishing all
the events to a layer above.
And then we that's where
our enterprise data is
deep down in the enterprise.
About that, we have
internet enterprise data,
which is stored in a data store
layer or running on Kubernetes.
This is where we have Cassandra,
Sparks, Solar, Elasticsearch,
Kafka, in memory data stores,
Spark for in-memory processing.
Data has no end and no
beginning right now.
So it cannot fit in memory.
So we've got to find a way
to process this continuously.
We have Redis as well.
And we consciously
made a decision
to run all our data services
in a separate cluster.
And the reason is very simple.
You have different challenges
when you think about networks.
You have Node IPs that
need to be exposed.
You have to think about
backup strategies.
How do you do that
at scale using arc?
You've got terabytes
and terabytes of data.
How do you do that?
You've got to think differently.
In fact, we started a
journey three years ago.
So we've been investing upstream
with various technologies
and strategies through
partners to enable
us to do this at scale.
We also have graph databases
that we use for customer 360,
and permissions and
entitlements that we have.
Above that layer, you've got the
digital services, our stateless
applications.
We've separated the concerns.
We're constantly rebuilding
our applications from source.
Our platforms are torn
down every 60 days.
We have to roll it over.
And with that, we have to
roll all the traffic over.
So imagine if you're
supporting more
than 50 different channels.
It's a highly complex
exercise to have all this done
in a unified manner.
So we have the API Management
Gateway, which is Apigee.
We've been partnering with
Google for a long time
now, almost four
years with Apigee.
And the data, the
traffic shaping
is done from the
Apigee layer on top.
And above that, we've got
open endpoint independence,
which means we believe
in co-creating value
in the ecosystem.
That's the reason why
we published open APIs.
And we have a single strategy
for all our consumers.
It's Open ID Connect
with OAuth too.
And you can see that we have
other consumers as well.
We have Salesforce, which is--
our internal staff is using
that for customer support.
New partners-- we also
have our partners building
their own experiences with APIs.
And we have to do this at
scale with all our services
changing continuously
multiple times a day.
How do we do that?
So we have fairly--
an outside in based architecture
approach with everything we do.
We think about customers
first and then start
building a solutions.
Now because we have
this architecture, which
is on the cloud
running on Kubernetes,
we can spin up
multiple environments.
Every developer can have
an end to end environment.
And you can see there,
we snap all your data
that's been published
and all the events
that are coming through
almost real time.
We split that up.
And we can create an end to end
environment saying, hey, only
are digital engineers
can access this area.
So we control the blast radius
of the access in that area.
And it's all live in production.
So it's like saying I've
got a mini production
environment running.
I can have a few of
these running depending
on the features that
we are trying to build,
because this is all
about accelerating
our path to production.
Now I believe Netflix published
some kind of a paper on this.
And they call this forklifting,
if I'm not mistaken.
Then once you're happy with
that, we move over to Beta.
Beta is where we constantly
working with our partners.
We are working with
our internal staff.
And of course, we
invite external clients
to also come and comment and
give us feedback continuously.
Lastly, of course,
once that's done,
we can move to production.
This is really important.
This is a strategy.
That's the secret sauce that
makes us successful when we
have to innovate really fast.
Coming to how we did
this, I'll quickly
tell you about how
we've implemented this
and how we industrialized
Kubernetes.
So we've got Kubernetes
running, of course.
And when you have
to think in terms
of where do you draw the
line between what a platform
team should be doing and
what the product team should
be doing?
So of course, you
have Kubernetes.
If you had just
one or two teams,
you wouldn't have to worry too
much about shipping software
out.
But if you have, let's say,
about 40 teams like we do,
and over hundreds and
hundreds of developers,
you have to think
differently about how do you
industrialize this.
We are a highly
regulated environment.
We are regulated.
We have obligations
for regulators.
Hence we have to make
sure that everything
is traced and audited.
So we use GitOps.
All our governance related
parameters and metadata
are stored in Git.
And if you guys are
not aware of GitOps,
have a search on the
internet and you'll
learn a lot more about it.
It's very interesting topic.
Essentially, we can store
all our metadata in Git.
And you can have
approvals and everything
done using Git itself.
So this is where you have
permissions based on, hey,
this is the structure
of the team.
Within this team, this
is the release manager.
This is the approver.
This is how you get
stuff into production.
If you are a
release manager, you
can only get stuff into
production using the JIRA.
You can't go and deploy
it from anywhere else.
You have to have security
boundaries drawn out
pretty clearly.
And this is why you have
to look at guardrails
that are really important.
It could be detective.
It could be preventive.
You have to think about that.
Another thing that really,
really challenged us
when we went down
the Kubernetes route
was you end up
with 15 x density.
Everybody is deploying software
in development, in test.
And you are running over
capacity all the time.
So you have to
manage your capacity.
You have to manage the
[? expiry ?] of these named
spaces.
And that itself is a challenge.
We have use access reviews,
which again, being regulated,
we have to produce all of that.
Now moving further up, you think
in terms of secret management,
at the moment, we
have a strategy
for managing all our
secrets and certificates.
That's home grown.
And we're now moving
towards HashiCorp world.
If you had 50 ways
of doing this,
you would not be able
to industrialize this.
It would be a nightmare.
So what we do is we have a
standard pattern in place.
We have standard APIs in place
that delivers this for us.
So for us to shift over to
the vault would be really,
really very simple.
Another good example
here would be how
do you handle vulnerabilities?
We practice SEG DevOps.
Our security team are
building all the APIs
on top of all the scanners.
And they handle all
the false positives.
As you all know,
it's a nightmare.
Think in terms of how you
manage false positives.
It's almost
impossible to do that.
So we do that ourselves.
And our entire ecosystem--
we built our entire ecosystem
on top of Kubernetes
to enable us
to do this at speed and scale.
As you move up--
as I move up, this is what
we're trying to say here.
We tried to absorb all
the responsibilities
from the developers,
all the platform-related
responsibilities.
Anything that we're repeating,
if we are doing anything
once or twice, if
it's repeatable,
we try and absorb that
into the platform.
About 98% of the patterns
that we have are all reusable.
So here you see the lines
going further and further up.
And we want to move
the line of innovation
closer and closer
to the developers.
So they only have one
job and one job alone.
And that is to create
world class experiences
for our customers.
And the last thing
I'd like to say there,
is when you think in
terms of scale here,
and we are constantly moving
our clusters, recreating them,
you got to bleed the traffic
over to the latest services.
So what we do is match.
Our platform allows us to match
clusters, match name spaces,
match services within
clusters using synthetics.
And then once we're ready,
we flick the traffics across.
So this is happening
continuously during the day.
In fact, we do not do
any releases [? on it. ?]
We do it live.
Everything we do is live.
As a bank, it's quite
challenging to get there.
But we've got there because
we are on the cloud today.
So the next thing
I'd like to say here
is this is an example,
a quick example of how
we route our traffic.
We have, let's say,
white label partners
building their own solutions
using version 1.5, version 1.8
of all our services and APIs.
You have Macquarie
Bank pointing to 1.7.
And let's say you had a bug.
You would say I
want to create 1.8.
You going to drop that in.
It'll take you
about five minutes.
What we do is build products, a
namespace related to a product.
So let's say you got
personal banking namespace.
You'd have a wealth namespace,
an identity namespace,
a business
[? mounting ?] namespace
and so on and so forth.
And you'll find most of
the time your applications,
your architecture, your
topology of your namespaces
will always, always
reflect the way
you build your software
in the organization.
And it's a fact.
You will be doing that.
And if you do that,
it's a challenge.
But we'll come to that
challenge as well.
Now, what we do here
is also you could just
drop in or change any
microservice here.
What we prefer to do is move
them as a set or as a product
through the entire lifecycle
from development right
through to integration, unit
testing, and production, lab
and production.
Our new features, as
I mentioned before, we
have no limit to the number
of nodes you want to create.
We have multiple clusters.
We have different clusters for
different purposes, enterprise
services, legacy applications.
We have digital services,
stateful, stateless,
you name it, we have it.
And we have multiple
touch environments.
And we have to do
this constantly.
So having said that, we are
now releasing to production
almost 60 to 100 times a day.
So what does it mean for us?
What's next for us?
And this is interesting.
We have spent a lot of effort
in the past three years
managing Kubernetes.
It's not an easy task.
It's not for the faint hearted.
And we've also been
curating from upstream
and bringing it in.
We actually working
with partners upstream.
And it's a challenge for us.
What we want to do is outsource
all this responsibility
to Google.
We want to make sure that we
are focusing wholly and solely
on one thing alone, which
is building business
value for our customers
and our partners.
Now if you think about
what next for us,
I talked about how we are
building our software today.
It's fairly siloed.
We have products.
And let's see our
business banking world
and personal banking.
And now you want
to start creating
services that can be shared.
This is where the
challenge comes.
So you build it.
You build a
namespace, and you say
this is the payment gateway
for all the products.
And then you start
thinking in terms of, hey,
I need to worry
about the service
to service interactions.
I need to start thinking
about east-west interactions,
rather than north, south.
That's what we do a lot.
We have a lot of API.
We use a lot of the API
gateway with the authentication
and authorization.
What also happens in our
current state architecture
is we happen to have
all sorts of patterns
of authentication
and authorization
spanned across all our services.
We have defense by
depth, of course.
But just to manage that
is a huge overhead.
A lot of automation goes in.
A lot of energy goes in.
We expend a lot of effort in
trying to do this efficiently.
So we would love to
have one control plane.
We'd love to simplify
that entire architectures
so we can enable our
teams to morph into more
feature-based development.
We want the flexibility
to move faster and faster.
And we believe that that's
slowing us down at the moment.
So we are excited to
be working with Google.
And what's it called again?
It's Anthos.
I'm still getting used to it.
I just got announced today.
So I remember it as CSP.
So excited to work
with Google on this.
We are hoping that you
continue to curate technology
from upstream, bring it to
us, make it end price great,
and any price
radian we can focus
on what we do best, which
is building the business
value for our customers.
Lastly, I like to say
that we at Macquarie,
continue to aspire to dream
in months, plan in days,
and ship in minutes.
I'm around here
after this meeting.
If there's any other questions,
I'm happy to take them.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
ALLAN NAIM: Thank you Rajay.
So we designed Anthos
really to cater
to the needs of enterprise
customers like Macquarie.
So the example that
Rajay walked through
is very much the area
that we're looking
at addressing with Anthos
so that as customers, you
can outsource a lot of the
complexities associated
with managing these
environments and being
able to implement centralized
governance across environments
that are very
heterogeneous in nature,
but do it in a way that's
predictable and consistent.
That's really what
Anthos is about.
So today we announced Anthos.
It's the latest
innovation from Google.
It's around hybrid and
multi-cloud computing.
It's for modernizing
applications, automating
policy, and it provides
you security at scale.
And it'll run on prem, in
Google Cloud, and other clouds.
So part of the challenge with
hybrid traditionally has been--
hybrid is complex.
When you start thinking
about deploying applications
across multiple
environments, you
start addressing challenges
around operational overhead
and cost, because you're having
to use many different tools
and bring in people of
different skill sets.
And it's not just
about the technology.
It's about the
people and process.
That's complicated in terms of
how you make all that happen.
Kubernetes did a really
good job at abstracting away
the underlying infrastructure.
And we're all happy about.
Just show of hands, how
many people out here
are using Kubernetes?
That's awesome.
And Kubernetes has done
a very good job there.
But as you start building
more and more containerized
applications and exposing
services, and services
that live on prem, in the
cloud, on other clouds,
how do you manage all
these interactions?
How do you implement
a preventive policy
across who can do what and
what applications are allowed
to do cross this environment?
These are really
hard things to do.
And then getting
started with Kubernetes,
typically, cloud providers
do a very good job
at providing managed
Kubernetes implementations.
But what if you have to get
started outside of cloud?
There's 10, 20, 30
distributions out there.
Each is different.
But what if you had an ability
to get a Google supported
Google distribution
of Kubernetes, which
is Google Kubernetes Engine,
and pretty much run it anywhere
starting with on prem?
And that's what we've
done with Anthos.
We provided a GKE
on prem distribution
that you can run in
your data centers that's
fully consistent with
GKE in the cloud,
so that you can
build applications
for one environment and be
able to run them anywhere.
And then let's not forget
about operations, the day
two experience,
the ability to be
able to define central policy,
and apply these policies
across all of your
cluster environments
in a consistent fashion.
Rajay mentioned the
whole notion of GitOps.
This is our goal with Anthos.
It's really to drive
the GitOps model
so you can check your
policy and config
and to Git, and have them
applied deterministicly
across your cluster
environments,
regardless of where
they're running.
And then we're providing
a centralized monitoring
and logging framework via
Stackdriver and Prometheus
for your entire operations for
your hybrid environments as
well.
So let's talk about how GCP
and Anthos can help you.
Grace, you start
off the presentation
talking about all the challenges
that you're seeing out there.
So let's walk through
these challenges
and talk about how
we address them.
So Grace started off
talking about regulation.
Customers operate in a
very regulated environment.
Google Cloud has achieved
independent verification
of security, privacy,
and compliance controls,
achieving certification
against global standards.
So that's done.
Now let's talk about
infrastructure requirements.
So Anthos enables
platform operators
to consistently run
and centrally manage
their Kubernetes clusters
across on prem and the cloud.
This includes GKE
On Prem, that I just
talked about, which is
a GKE distribution that
runs on premise.
On top of that, Anthos
provides centralized management
for your Kubernetes
clusters and services.
Now these services could
be container-based,
or you could have
a virtual machine
that has an envoy proxy that
now becomes part of the service
mesh.
But you now have the
ability to centrally manage
this environment across
on prem and public cloud.
And the important
thing is reducing
the operational
overhead of operating
across this hybrid environment.
That's key.
That's been one of the
biggest adoption blockers,
is the complexity and
the operational costs.
Our aim is to reduce that.
For applications that have
data sensitivity and locality
concerns, Google Cloud
data loss prevention API
can be used to classify data to
ensure that it remains or gets
set where it's allowable.
So we have sessions this
week on the DLP API.
Highly recommend
you check into that.
And there's also a booth that
you can learn more about it.
Anthos has been designed
from the ground up
to manage hybrid resources.
And we enable you
to configure policy
so that you meet the
standards around your business
continuity.
That's been very key for us.
Platform operators can logically
separate workloads and teams,
either using clusters
or namespaces.
The idea here is Kubernetes,
as you start using it,
you have to make
important decisions around
do I create one cluster
for all my teams?
Do I have a cluster per team?
Do I create a
namespace per team?
We're providing all
the various tooling
to enable you to
make the choice.
You have freedom of
choice around what
model works for you.
But then define config
across all these environments
in a consistent fashion.
And a common unified
monitoring and logging service
across your hybrid
environments really that
minimizes the risk
with exposing services.
Now let's talk about the
security team requirements.
So Anthos allows you
to run your workloads
and have your data
reside where you need it.
And again, this is where
DLP comes in, where you can
classify your data ensure
that data doesn't end up where
in places it shouldn't.
And then you can
leverage existing CI/CD
tooling to implement
container supply chain,
and implement things like image
scanning binary authorization
and so forth across your
container supply chain.
And you get real
time visibility.
Think of Istio as real time
monitoring for your services.
You're getting real
time visibility
and integrated logging
across your services
that are running in
this hybrid environment.
Now the cool thing
here is really
around configuration management
and centralized governance.
So Anthos brings this notion
of GitOps into reality.
So you've heard from Rajay.
For the last couple
of years, they've
been developing this
environment really
that's very GitOps driven.
We want to bring
GitOps to the masses
so that you can just take
advantage of it from day one.
And the idea here
is really bringing
to reality this whole notion
of separation of concerns.
At Google we operate
in a model where
we have cluster operators,
application ops, and security
admins really operating
independently, but working
together.
And we're bringing this model
of separation of concerns
so that administrators can
define preventative policies
that can be centrally
defined and propagated
across a hybrid environment.
That's really key for us.
So Anthos configuration
management
enables cluster, security,
network admin teams
to operate independently and
define configuration centrally.
And configuration can be owned
by these independent teams.
And it really decouples the
infrastructure and security
concerns away from
the development team.
That's really the idea here.
You can start small.
You can have every
team go and build out
their own environment.
You can define these
policies and can
fix for each one of
these environments.
And then you can centrally
govern them over time,
so that you're not introducing
friction from the start.
Developers are super
critical for us.
Our goal here is to enable
developers to move fast.
Really, when you
think about it, Anthos
is a platform for
agile development.
It's not in a sense
opinionated to the point
where developers can't do what
they feel comfortable in doing,
but it provides a framework to
enable developers to interact
with the rest of the
broader team in a way that's
frictionless.
And the idea is to
enable developers
to be able to deploy
applications transparently
into these multiple environments
that look very different.
And then finally,
we have services
that we've built
at Google to really
make the life of
applications, DevOps easier,
things like Cloud Build
that are tightly integrated
with our container supply chain.
We provide these
add-ons for Anthos.
But we'll work with any CI/CD
tool that's there on the market
to provide a great experience.
And really, the goal here
is around consistency,
and ensuring that
you're not spending time
learning different tools
for different environments.
GRACE MOLLISON: So
that sounds great.
So let me just summarize what
you've just kind of spoke
to me about, is the fact
that you're telling me
that I can actually get rid
of all the operational craft
so that I can have a
single pane of glass
to manage both on
prem and in the cloud?
ALLAN NAIM: Yes.
GRACE MOLLISON:
Oh, that's so cool.
And also that I
can then just focus
on the business value,
which is basically
what I'm being paid for.
And I love the idea of the
fact that I can segregate data.
You've mentioned various
ways that we can do that.
And it gives me a solid
foundation and room
to grow as Rajay
showed us last--
earlier.
So this sounds great,
but how do I get started?
ALLAN NAIM: Who
wants to see a demo?
Enough talk.
Let's see some of
this in action.
So I'm going to invite the Duke
up on stage to make this real.
JAMES DUKE: Hi everyone.
My name is James Duke.
I'm in our professional
services group.
Nicknamed the Duke,
like Allan says.
I have the challenging
task today of showing you
what this would actually
look like in practice.
And so Grace has told us--
thank you for that--
all of the problems
that we see out there--
we've heard from Rajay
how Macquarie have solved this.
And we've heard from
Allan how CSP solves this.
Let's see what that actually
looks like in practice.
So imagine the workflow.
You are a financial
services customer
with your business, which
I expect a number of you
are out here already.
And you now want to roll
out some kind of new service
within your business,
whatever it might be.
For the purposes
of this demo, I'm
going to use a use
a demo, which shows
a very simple application,
which is just grabbing data
from the Pub/Sub, the
Google Pub/Sub API.
Now to actually
release that, what
might our Git Ops
process look like?
Well, the first thing you
would likely want to do
is review and update
your security posture
and your guardrails
that Rajay mentioned,
in order to accommodate
that new application.
So the place to do that is
going to be in a repository.
In this case, I'm going
to use Google Cloud Source
Repositories to show you
what that would look like.
You will go in there,
review, and update and submit
that change.
At that point in time,
any of the governance
process that you have would run.
We only have 10
minutes here, so I'm
going to skip the asking
my manager for approval.
But in theory, you could put
any of the workflows in there
you want.
Then those changes would then
propagate out automatically
into all of the fleet and
all of the environments
that are managed by Anthos.
Finally, we can validate.
Those changes are in place.
And then finally, as we've
mentioned here, profit.
At the end of the
day, this is a tool
to solve business problems.
And so in order to do that,
what I'm going to show you
is the use of a custom resource
definition and accompanying
controller.
And what that does is the CRD,
or custom resource definition,
it allows me to define
something that's
Kubernetes does not
currently know about
or that Anthos does not
currently know about.
The controller then allows me to
write the logic that translates
that resource definition into
something that Kubernetes
understands.
And it could be anything.
For this case, what
we're going to do is,
we're going to grant this app
access to the outside world.
And in order to do that,
we will use an Istio.
So along the top
here, you see what
it looks like conceptually.
And in the bottom, you'll
see what it is in practice.
All right.
If we could switch
over the view,
you see here I
have a graph, which
is showing the traffic, the
consumption from the Pub/Sub
API for this
particular application.
As you can see, it's
effectively zero.
The peak there is
from this morning
when I tested this demo.
So what I'm going to do is
submit an actual change.
So you see here in the
logs deadline exceeded,
deadline exceeded,
because the application is
unable to access the API.
I am going to push this change
into my GitOps source of truth.
And I'm going to add it.
I'm going to commit.
I'm going to call it Allow
Access, because that's
exactly what it does.
And then I'm going to push
it into the source repo.
Now what that will do is take
my custom resource definition
and push it into my repository.
Then Google's configuration
management tool
is going to pull
that out of the repo
and push it out to all of the
clusters that are in scope.
If I show you the CRD itself,
we can see what it does.
So it is of type application
security boundary.
This is a custom type
that we have defined,
which specifies a set
of application security
boundaries.
It's called Why and it applies
to the namespace deal app 1.
Imagine we are in FSI company.
We have many, many
different things spaces
doing many different things.
This particular namespace
is for a particular type
of application, which is
doing it brokering deals
with third parties
from a marketplace.
And all I'm going to
do is allow access
to Google APIs with the
protocol Https and port 443.
Then behind the scenes, config
management is pushing us out.
Now if I refresh
my logs, you will
see now I have received
B, received Hello 1,
received Hello 2.
That's the traffic that is
being pushed into this Pub/Sub
subscription.
So now by pushing that
one CRD into my Git Repo,
I have opened up just
for that namespace access
to that one particular
set of APIs.
Now, this is Kubernetes.
So we can use the hierarchy.
We can specify a namespace.
We could do it global.
We can be quite
specific about it.
We can apply it to specific
namespaces in specific security
rings.
So imagine now that this--
well, this particular demo
there is an on prem component.
We've created the
system in such a way
as there are two security
teams, one of which
encompasses on prem and
cloud, and one of which
is just on prem.
So if I have those
particular workloads,
then I know I can't
push into the cloud.
I can keep them in
those namespaces
which are security tiers,
which only on prem.
Now as you can see, that
traffic is appearing.
And as you can see, right on
cue, the traffic is spiking.
So this is a very trite
example, because all I've done
is really like, for those
of you familiar with Istio,
what I've really done is
create a service entry.
However, think about this.
That CRD is not
limited to one thing.
It can incorporate
almost anything.
So what we are-- our goal here
is to write these templates
and share them with you.
If we could switch back
to the slides, please.
We will create a
situation where we
produce these templates
sized CRDs which we will then
publish to the world.
And the idea is to
solve Rajay's point.
If they were going to
do this a second time,
how could we do it faster?
How could we lean
on Google to provide
more of the best
practices out of the box
that I can consume very easily?
So we would produce
these templates,
publish them in
GitHub to the world.
And they will allow you
to very, very quickly
bring these in and build on
top of them and grow them,
and to make your adoption--
your migration to this process
much, much faster.
On top of that Google
professional services,
which is the team I'm in,
and our partner organizations
are also putting together
services packages
so we can help
with this process.
So a combination of a
smart trained people--
sounds-- I just called
myself smart there.
That sound very bad.
Everybody else
who's really smart
and me are able to deliver
these projects with you,
bye leaning on some of
these templated CRDs.
And our goal here is that
this answers that question
of what do we want from CSP?
And this is what it would
look like in practice.
Thank you.
ALLAN NAIM: Thank you, James.
[APPLAUSE]
So today we announced Anthos.
And we invite you to come
down the journey with us.
If you're interested
in evaluating it,
test driving it, please reach
out to your Google Contact.
We think it's going to be
an exciting journey ahead
and we welcome your feedback.
And we look forward to going
down this journey with you
over the next several months.
[MUSIC PLAYING]